j'accueille maintenant auteur cécile
tremblay microbiologiste-infectiologue
au chum on sort l'auteur tremblay
bonsoir mesdames galipeau alors comment
avez vous réagi à ces mesures annoncées
par le gouvernement ce soir et ce
qu'elle était pour vous nécessaire
oui elle était nécessaire et j'étais
très contente qu'on les annonce je pense
qu'il faut agir sur les deux fronts
accélérer dramatiquement la vaccination
de la troisième dose et illimitée les
contacts si on veut préserver notre
système de santé durant par les fêtes
qu'est ce qui rend la situation aussi
critique c'est que plus les cas vont se
multiplier plus il va y avoir
d'hospitalisation c'est ça qu'on craint
c'est un effet de dominos en fait c'est
sûr qu'on n'est pas encore certain de la
sévérité du variant micron mais fort
probablement qu'il est relativement
similaire ou delta donc imaginez si on a
dix fois plus de cas en termes de
pourcentage de gens qui seront
hospitalisés on est certain que ça va
occasionner plus de signalisation
l'autre élément ccîo beaucoup beaucoup
de transmission communautaire comme
c'est le cas présentement sa double ou
deux jours il ya du personnel a senti
aussi que devient malade et puis quand
ils sont atteints de la coved il pourra
peut-être en quarantaine donc ça donne
des ressources encore moins de
ressources dans les hôpitaux pour
prendre soin des patients parce que la
capacité du système c'est pas juste le
nombre de lits physique c'est le
personnel pour s'en occuper alors on
pourrait à mon avis atteindre
capacité maximale avant même le mois de
juin c'est intéressant parce qu'on pense
toujours qu'à un virus qui est moins qu
est plus contagieux mais moins virulent
et moins dangereux en fait oui mais on
n'est même pas certain qu'il est moins
virulent nos des données du danemark qui
vive
l'éclosion au micro depuis plusieurs
semaines déjà qu'une temps de faire des
statistiques sur leur cas et leur tour
de spécialisation avec le variable au
micro est le même que celui qu'ils
avaient avec le verrière delta points 80
pour ça donc dans leur corps tout cas
c'est pas d'eric était moins virulent en
afrique chute c'était différent mais les
populations sont différents plus jeunes
prennent et exposé auparavant à de
nombreuses vagues de deux cabines donc
c'est difficile de encore de se faire
une bonne idée sur la virulence de ce
microbe mais ce qu'on sait maintenant
avec certitude c'est que les deux doses
ne sont pas suffisantes que ça prend
cette troisième dose et donc on se
demande un peu est ce que le
gouvernement n'a pas tardé finalement à
élargir l'accès
ça fait plusieurs semaines que plusieurs
d'entre nous souvent l'importance et la
nécessité d'administrer la troisième
dose le plus rapidement possible ça
avait déjà été déterminé par plusieurs
juridictions que ce soit lagence de
santé publique en europe que ce soit les
américains avec le cil ici et même le
canada donc tout le monde s'entendait
pour dire que ça prenait la troisième
dose même dans le contexte de delta
parce qu'on sentait que l'immunité
commencé à baisser dans la population
générale particulièrement chez les
personnes âgées mais aussi dans la
population générale alors arrive au
micron qui l'on sait est plus résistant
aux vaccins donc c'est ça va de soi et
puis au micron là on en est on
on le connaît depuis un mois déjà c'est
pas juste deux semaines il pas paru la
semaine dernière c'est depuis un mois
qu'on est au courant de micron et puis
et puis clairement la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on sait qu'avec la troisième
dose ça réussi à rehausser notre
immunité suffisamment pour nous protéger
très correctement contre au micro donc
on sait qu'on est un outil efficace
c'est d'autant plus important de
distribuer le plus rapidement possible
oui vous êtes d'accord aussi avec le rat
le fait qu'on puisse raccourcir le délai
la entre la deuxième et la troisième
dose tout à fait parce que ce délai
était arbitraire ils étaient seulement
établi à la partir des données qui
montré que limiter commence à baisser
six mois après avoir reçu
la deuxième dose dans la population
générale mais on savait que dans des
sous groupes ça d'elle c'est pas mal
avance alors c'était donc un tabac de 6
mois c'était pour dire c'est pour mon
nécessaire de l'année istres et avant
mais là au micron change la donne
complètement parce qu'on sait que
l'immunité n'est plus bonne du tout pour
l'ensemble de la population après deux
doses peu importe le délai alors la
majorité des autres juridictions sont
allés avec trois mois en europe ces
trois mois dans le reste du canada ces
trois mois bon ici on a décidé quatre
mois en fait moi je pense que on doit
mettre tout en oeuvre pour accélérer la
vaccination de toute la population
je suis bien d'accord qu il yal par
tranches d'âge ou en étant les plus
vulnérables en premier mais tout cela
doit se faire très vite oui
malheureusement on n'a pas encore tout à
fait les bras pour donner ces vaccins là
et en terminant rapidement l'auteur
trembler la réduction des contacts est
aussi nécessaire parce que la
vaccination c'est pas suffisant a
finalement absolument parce que de toute
façon si on vaccine les gens maintenant
leur immunité ce rapport aussi avant
deux semaines alors qu'est-ce qui en a
comme mesure en attendant qui très
efficace et de diminuer les contacts je
sais que c'est difficile parce que pour
moi aussi c'est difficile 1 2 on veut
vivre on aurait voulu voir d'autres
familles de façon plus élargie durant le
temps des fêtes des mines tout ça mais
on sait que dans le fond on fait ça pour
protéger les gens qu'on aime alors
c'est difficile c'est un effort
supplémentaire mais c'est ce que de plus
efficaces pour empêcher qu et de la
propagation alors se laver les mains
porter le masque d'un petit
rassemblement protéger nos personnes
vulnérables
on a tous dans nos familles quelqu'un
qui vient de vivre un camp sacs réussi à
passer à travers la chimiothérapie ce
serait vraiment moche lequel marc
d'accueil de vraiment merci beaucoup
docteur tremblay toujours éclairant